while an island off the coast of  Scotland something was summoned from the  depths of hell  [Music]  something that would end mankind you sir  things he worried about to show up  you did  we face every birth there is and yet you  take me in  hello son made me a goddamn weapon  where's my [ __ ] buyer there  listen up ladies and gentlemen out there  there's a fifth-century sorceress who  want to bring down the curtain on London  and the world  great homework  why do you fight for those who hates and  fear you  you are meant for this  out of the ashes  okay I'd appreciate a prophecy with more  relatable Stig's haven't we got to be  saving the world or something yeah okay  come on get your face off  yeah come on let's do this  [Music]  be my kid  we belong together here in fact  [Applause]  we do but it's not gonna work you know  cuz I'm a Capricorn and you're [ __ ]  [Music]  [Music]